bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy recordaremos a jimi hendrix
uno de los mejores guitarristas de todos
los tiempos a propósito de los 50 años
de su muerte
[Música]
el 18 de septiembre de 1970 la revista
rolling stones anunció que jimi hendrix
con apenas 27 años había muerto nacido
en eeuu
hendrix logró inmortalizarse con apenas
5 años de producción musical en la cual
logró más de un centenar de lanzamientos
su talento era la guitarra la cual podía
tocar con los dientes entre las piernas
o detrás de la espalda
[Música]
e
ah
[Música]
para townshend miembro de la banda
de hendrix modificó el sonido del rock
mucho más profundamente que the beatles
bueno no propiamente hablando de las
composiciones pero sí en el sonido de la
guitarra la década de esplendor de
hendrix fue la de los años 60 años
marcados por el mayo del 68 francés la
liberación del hippismo la guerra de
vietnam el hombre en la luna y por
supuesto woodstock pero hendrix
necesitaría de un impulso para lograr
darse a conocer y ese empujón se lo dio
la por entonces novia del legendario
guitarrista de the rolling stones keith
richards tras quedar asombrada al verlo
tocar en un club nocturno de nueva york
linda se lo presentó a su novio richards
quien luego se encargó de recomendarlo
con varios productores británicos chas
chandler- antiguo bajista de the animals
se convirtió en su representante y se lo
llevó a londres en el reino unido- jimi
hendrix conformó la banda de jimi
hendrix experience con la cual se
de gira por europa uno de sus sencillos
más exitosos fue por paul hayes que
entró en el top de la lista musical del
reino unido- y se posicionó en el tercer
lugar escuchamos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a pesar de que a mediados de los 60
hendrix contaba con sencillos que
duraron en el top de las listas del
reino unido- hasta 33 semanas en el otro
lado del atlántico en su patria su éxito
no despuntaba pero en 1967 esto cambió
el lugar fue el festival de pop de
monterrey en california en donde hendrix
le prendió fuego a su guitarra
fue necesario el ritual para que el
público estadounidense apreciará sus
estados de ternura salvajismo elegancia
o sexualidad todo junto en una misma
canción como consigna jazz o break
escritor del libro stonestreet los nueve
meses que cambiaron la historia del rock
y así muy pronto llegaría en 1969 el año
en que woodstock marcó la vida de
cientos de miles de jóvenes que buscaban
liberarse a través de la consigna de
tres días de paz y música o tres días de
sexo drogas y rock and roll así
respondió hendrix cuando le preguntaron
sobre el festival de música más icónico
de la historia en el cual él participó y
fue un éxito por el hecho de que fue la
reunión más grande de gente en un
sentido musical podría haberse
organizado un poco más pequeño pero fue
un éxito total en comparación con todos
los demás festivales y que los
organizadores trataron de llamar aquí y
allá y simplemente difundió armonía y
comunicación no hubo violencia en
absoluto lo cual es completamente
diferente nadie pudo esperarlo con la
variedad de artistas
como quieras llamarlo al preguntarme a
hendrix si wittstock cambió la cultura
estadounidense esto respondió ha estado
cambiando mucho incluso antes de los
tiempos de quin el doctor martin luther
king ha habido muchos cambios pero
algunas personas después de la emocionó
de relajarse dicen sí estuvo maravilloso
veamos qué más podemos captar de esto y
ya sabes se están produciendo muchos
cambios ahora es el momento de que todos
estos cambios se conecten con cerca de
un año después hendrix murió en londres
al tomar 18 dosis de somníferos aún así
se desconoce hasta el día de hoy si se
trató de un suicidio más de 50 años
después
jimi hendrix es considerado como una
leyenda del movimiento de contracultura
estadounidense y un icono para los
melómanos de todas las edades así
recordamos a jimi hendrix
soy andrés suárez jaramillo gracias por
compartir estas historias que las
encuentran en france 24 punto com
[Música]
ah